every day that I drive home from this
job I have a practice I listen I try and
figure out what's going on and so I'll
listen to the different news sources
right and I'll switch around I'll listen
to obviously the left I'll try to listen
to the center and then I try and listen
to Fox News as well and I listen to all
of them and I do I try and think you
know I mean I want to understand I don't
want to just be in my bubble everyone
says we're in a bubble I don't want to
be in a bubble and yet when it comes to
Donald Trump no one can agree and the
first question I have for you is in your
opinion as a legal analyst and someone
who really knows the law knows the
Constitution do you think it's possible
that Trump committed an impeachable
offense do you think he is going to be
impeached or is this a guy who serves
out his his four-year term okay I do
think he serves out his four-year term I
don't think there's much doubt about
that did he commit an impeachable
offense I think it's possible you know
one of the things that's different from
the 70s and and Watergate and rich is
that is that our attention spans are so
much shorter you know it was the
Watergate was a two-year investigation
and with this is I mean you know Trump's
only been president for 150 days and you
know I do think there's serious grounds
to investigate and particularly for
obstruction of justice for shutting
trying to shut down the FBI
investigation of his national security
advisor Michael Flynn and then firing
James Comey when he didn't do that but
you know with the Republican Congress I
think regardless of what the result of
that investigation is I think there's
almost no chance he'll be impeached
right so I sometimes feel like when you
said 150 days it's it is unbelievable to
me that we've been living in this world
for only a hundred and fifty days it
feels like it's been about three years
now absolutely and I keep thinking well
there's probably oh there's another year
and then we'll have an election no it's
a mind-blowing it is unbelievably the
pace of news has been like nothing
nothing I've ever seen in my whole
career I also think in my opinion the
highs are too high too quickly the lows
are too low too quickly so that people
almost get I mean he was in office for
several days and people were using the
impeachment word
and it almost felt like people on the
left
sometimes we're punching themselves out
obviously they need to investigate but
people get they lose their minds over
one new cycle and then it switches to
the next news cycle and they lose their
minds and you get to a point where maybe
people get inured they get dulled to the
idea well an IV engagement Democrats
have a real risk in that that they are
betting so much that there is some you
know cataclysmic scandal coming that if
and when 2018 comes along 2020 comes
along and there has not been a you know
convincing proof of some serious
wrongdoing they need some argument other
than you know Donald Trump is corrupt
they need to go to the public and say
health care the economy issues that
affect people in their day to day lives
that's an argument they need to make
you